clay travis has taken over for rush
limbaugh in his spot he and buck sexton
they host the clay travis buck sexton
show and we're happy to have him on
tonight clay great to see you
so it does seem like we're finally
allowed a little bit of air to note a
couple of obvious things
progress tucker first thanks for having
me
second uh these guys i think before long
bill maher
and jon stewart somebody slipped them a
red pill tucker and the next thing you
know you know they're gonna start
getting accused of
being fox news viewers because they
sound like somebody who's been hearing
the truth for the past
year as opposed to marinating in the
absurdity
that was the consensus opinion tucker
here's
what i would like to take as a glimmer
of hope comedy is supposed to be about
rebellion
it isn't supposed to be about enforcing
the dogma of the political party that is
in power
and finally we're starting to see a
little bit of rebellion from bill maher
and from jon stewart two smart guys that
looked at all of the facts
and finally are saying you know what the
wool has been pulled over our eyes it's
time to stand up and start to puncture
the reality of the majority party that
is ruling
with a lot of absurdity this is the
emperor emperor awares no clothes moment
to me they definitely feel red pilled
and i love it
so you make such a good point that
comedy art more broadly is supposed to
be
about rebellion it's raising a middle
finger in the face of the powerful and
saying
i'm sorry i have a special exemption to
say what is absolutely true and
everybody knows
and you can't do anything i mean
how shameful is it that we wait a year
and a half for someone to finally do
that i mean i've been i've been timing
it this whole time
i've been waiting for it tucker and and
i'm cautiously optimistic here
that what is starting to happen is we
are seeing a revolution
against the woke universe and that is
going to be led i really believe this
by creative people by artists who are
going to say wait a minute
you are constraining my ability to
comment on the larger culture
when you look at every one of my jokes
and try to dissect it to see whether or
not
the amherst faculty is happy with the
joke that i have told right
when all of this constrainment occurs
what typically
is going to be the response is a robust
you know just absolute embrace of
creativity
and you can't be creative while being
stifled within the bounds
of what the left-wing culture is
creating and i think what you're
starting to see from jon stewart and
from bill maher
kevin hart i don't know if you saw the
quotes that he had out there
about how he can't do comedy in this ma
and his current world
jerry seinfeld these are not people
these comedians who are known to be
you know particularly right-wing in
nature but what they embrace is freedom
and i think tucker what we're starting
to create here
is a world where you're either for
freedom and free thought or you're
against it
and comedians by their nature have to
rebel against anyone who's opposed to
free thought
man i hope you're right clay travis
we've spent the last year
one thing not one thing has been created
in this country not one thing
only destroyed i know and and so the
minute the creativity starts
news in general your show and fox news
in general is whether they want to
acknowledge it
or not giving these guys the space to
make the arguments that they are making
now
even if they consider fox news viewers
to be a pejorative
insult the reason why they can do that
let me repeat this too tucker because i
think it's significant
all those people laughing in the stephen
colbert audience
they would have been calling uh anybody
who made the comments that jon stewart
did over the past year
a conspiracy theorist a right-wing
zealot and imbecile
and now they're enjoying the humor of
the absurdity upon which they believed
ah you make a good point that's a better
way to think of it i think clay travis
great to see you
thank you tucker